right now we are learning more about the
fire that killed former zappos ceo
and entrepreneur tony shea investigators
releasing new details
and video here at noon the i-team's
david charns has been following this
investigation now for months
he's live in the newsroom with
information the i-team first reported in
the 8 news now app hi david
hey there alex so investigators say the
fire that killed tony shea was burning
for 10 minutes
before that first 9-1-1 call they say
shea was sleeping in a shed with a
propane tank blanket and candle which
had actually caught fire
earlier in the night now we're going to
show you some new pictures
inside the shed after that november fire
remember this happened in connecticut
shea died from his injuries a week later
investigators say shea was sleeping in
that shed after getting into a fight
with his girlfriend who is a longtime
zappos employee
right now what actually sparked that
fire remains a mystery
the fire marshal says it could be from
several things carelessly discarded
smoking materials that propane heater
candles
or he says it could have been
intentionally seeing body cam video
there
investigators saying shea liked candles
and there had actually been
another fire involving melted plastic on
a so
on a stove that is just two days before
the interviews with the witnesses said
that tony does
enjoy candles and that's been well
reported
it reminds him of a simpler time in his
life is what the common
trend or on the answers to that was
fire officials previously telling the
item they actually had to force their
way
into the storage area and pull shea out
they say
they tell us today that an electronic
lock you see right there
on the shed may have prevented rescuers
from getting
in or from shea getting out now we've
also learned today shea was traveling
with the nurse
it was actually scheduled to fly to
hawaii the day of that fire
we'll have much more video and play you
the 9-1-1 call from that night coming up
new this afternoon
at four o'clock live in the newsroom i'm
david charns 8 news now